the reason root pole is one of the first
poles to ask Americans what they think
about the new digital currency called
Bitcoin we found that about twenty
percent of americans say they've heard a
fair amount about it but most Americans
have heard hardly anything or nothing at
all we then went on to provide a brief
explanation about what bitcoin is and
then we asked Americans that they
thought it should be allowed or
prohibited we found that most Americans
thought the Bitcoin should be prohibited
this includes the people who know hardly
anything about it and in fact the more
people knew about it the less likely
they were to one abandoned so the groups
who supported allowing Americans to use
Bitcoin include political independence
gamers and young people some people when
they don't know what something is want
to ban it other people if they don't
know what something is they think it
should be allowed unless someone
convinces them that it's causing harm in
some way and this question really
delineates who those individuals are who
favored choice or favor prohibition